un nouveau film sur les écrans français
depuis le début de semaine depuis
mercredi son titre le cavalier solitaire
son héros c'est clint eastwood le
chouchou des spectateurs américains
il se trouve dans les films subtil
mélange de violence et de grands
sentiments font un véritable tabac aux
états unis d'où cette question qu'est ce
qui fait courir le bo clint la réponse
des lits vanier et le commentaire
ensuite de coluche soudain apparu un
cavalier solitaire et l'enfer
l'accompagnait coke ou de suite ce fut
l'hécatombe
comme au bon vieux temps du western de
seconde zone les premières amours depuis
je voulais faire un film qui exploite
les valeurs traditionnelles du western
mais sous une forme plus moderne plus
contemporaine pour ça la tradition est
lié le coup de feu fait mouche à tous
les coups et à la fin l'inévitable duel
certains l'appelaient ses gérants le
méchant qui raide mort
clint eastwood mais le beau le bon
clinton aussi jouer les policiers plutôt
méchant pendant quatre films
l'inspecteur harry n'avait que faire des
lois pour lui un seul credo une seule
justice le 357 magnum
en somme un américain modèle plus réduit
de quoi faire de vous la star
d'hollywood
et puis quel physique
à vrai dire pour tomber les fans clint
n'a pas besoin de revolver son regard
vers translucide suffit aujourd'hui
clint eastwood
c'est presque une légende comme gary le
cooper ou john le wayne john wayne
c'était vraiment le plus grand camp moi
j'ai grandi je suis toujours nostalgique
quand je le revois c'est lui qui
m'impressionnait le plus en fait si par
mégarde flynn s'écroulait dans un film a
battu par une balle perdue
il peut mourir tranquille pour la
majorité des jeunes américains cet homme
c'est déjà un mythe
gotcha très agréable à regarder
macmillan
pas méchante j'adore c'est pour ça j'ai
un devoir qu'est-ce que vous adorez lui
personnellement et soutiendra les
lecteurs c'est son jeu
j'ai fait très mal
je veux vivre